ready go
ready bite it the vision for icon really
is to allow airplane to be much more
accessible to consumers who have read
about flying their entire life
I'm Kirk Hawkins CEO and Founder bike on
aircraft and we're on the Hudson here in
New York City by George Washington
Bridge we're flying and demonstrating
the new icon 85 aircraft
the light sport aircraft category is a
new entry-level category that
effectively a small lightweight aircraft
that two people can fly and learn to fly
relatively quickly and easily we've
designed everything be as easy and it's
safe as we can possibly make it loaded
right now it's about two hundred fifty
thousand with all the options
a lot of work has been put in the
airplane so that it both flies well and
looks extremely well very easy to
operate easy getting out out of a very
simple cockpit section we call this is
the aviation section navigation
communication what we call configuration
where you change like the landing gear
and flaps and what we've done is put a
lot of R&D and development what we
really want to save is light airplanes
ever and some of the features we've done
has a built in parachute system which is
kind of the airbag core car it has an
angle of attack gauge and that gives you
a direct indication of how the wing is
doing so a new pilot a child could
actually tell if the wing is performing
well or not wings the wings are very
unique this is the first airplane that's
met the FAA standard for spin resistance
what that effectively means is that the
airplane is very forgiving if a pilot
makes a mistake and gets too slow stall
fall and lose control this airplane is
designed that if you do that it actually
forgives you for it and contains the fly
the wings layer plane full the airplane
can go on a trailer at that point and
you can trail it down the road park it
at your house keep it the airport where
you like you'll notice it the engines in
the back may get that propeller away
from these humans in the back so if I'm
a safety standpoint it's factly high
where the occupants interface with the
airplane yeah the idea really is the
consumer Iser products you will not have
an opportunity in a major metropolitan
area to go look at an airplane that you
could fly and then you could buy you can
be trained on and then to pick it out
and learn to fly